okay so I'm going to hand it over to dr.
Gregory Sadler and I hope you all
enjoyed this evening from thank you
thanks Scott so always do my my own
introduction my wife and I are both from
this area and ease in the back getting
all the tasting things ready we're back
here in Wisconsin after being gone for
about 20 years she in New York and I all
over the place and then in New York so
we're very happy to be back here in this
area I'm a philosopher by training but I
branch out into a number of other things
like you can see here some song culinary
matters as well and the talk that i'm
going to give tonight is you could say
it's within the field of astronomy which
means you sir does this history or study
of what is it we eat and and it's
something I've become more and more
interested in not only because I like to
eat but because food plays such an
important role in in all of our life and
culture and so there's a lot we can talk
about with that the the specific thing
that I'm going to focus on here is this
question about how many basic tastes or
flavors do we actually sense because
there's this you know we learn this all
in school right when they have the
tongue chart and although the 40s if
there's really only for tastes and now
they think there's perhaps a fifth taste
of umami that's that's not that's
something that that we at least think we
know to be the case and it's become
something like an unquestioned dogma of
late modern Western Approaches but
there's an entire history there usually
when you bring up the possibility of
other tastes people want to talk about
Chinese or Indian cooking and I'm not
going to do that here there's a great
and though those are both great vast
traditions and there's too much to talk
about in that but we have time for Q&A
at the end so we could discuss that what
I'm interested in here at something that
took place within our Western tradition
and it goes back all the way to
in Greece so this dominant for flavor
perspective is actually a very recent
development historically there's good
reasons why it developed the way that it
did and we'll talk about that but
another approach that was predominant in
the west through the early modern Eric
gravitated around a larger number of
tastes or flavors sometimes eight
sometimes nine sometimes more so I'm
going to talk about how that arose and
then we've got a lot of cool stuff for
you to taste that has these kinds of
flavors and Andy talked us into also
having a kind of bonus thing at the very
end that that she'll lead you through so
I'm not going to tell you quite what
we're doing with that yet so the
subjects of this this talk I'm going to
start off by telling the story very
briefly about how I got interested in
this question about the tastes and then
I'm going to jump into history and I've
got some handouts there for you some
very basic things and we'll talk about
the story of basic flavors and the
greek-speaking world before this guy
Aristotle and then I want to hit on
Aristotle and at that point we'll talk
about eight tastes and will actually
start tasting some some things so if you
came here to get something to eat or you
know looking for something after dinner
that that'll be that component and then
perhaps while you're still tasting those
things I'm going to tell you a little
bit more about what Aristotle himself
had to say about about tastes and food
that it's kind of interesting stuff and
then we'll talk about a bit more of
history how this this notion that that
is coming mostly from Aristotle ends up
going throughout Western medieval
thought and even Islamic thought about
food all the way to the modern era and
then we'll talk about where did the four
flavors come from why did we hit on that
in the 19th century and 20th century now
the way that I typically do my talks is
anytime you want to ask a question make
a comment just go ahead and do it I'm
very good at getting back on track sort
of like a you know an old horse that
knows the trail
you know so if you have any questions or
comments you don't have to wait until
the end for them I'm happy to go off on
tangents and come back but we also do
have some time reserved for questions
and answer at the end so how did I get
interested in this myself totally by
accident and as a matter of fact it was
sort of stumbling across things that I
had seen a number of times never paid
attention to and then running into
colleagues had equally done the same
thing both in the culinary world and in
the world of philosophy and ancient
texts so back in the 2000s I was doing a
lot of research focused on discussions
of anger which is another area of
research of mine and I was reading these
people that we call the church fathers
and so the church fathers are these
early Christian thinkers you know up
until about the eighth century or so
some of them are theologian some are
philosophers some are what we just
consider administrators and one of them
is this guy john de masking or John of
Damascus and he has a book that's called
the exposition of the Orthodox faith so
it's reading through the at to see some
stuff about anger and he had a chapter
in their titled on sensation and in it
he started talking about you know sight
and hearing and then when I got to
discussing taste he said yeah there's
all these different flavors I was like
wait a second so you know we've gotten
sweet salty bitter and sour we recognize
those and then he started talking about
all these other ones and he started
talking about it in such a way that it
would be sort of like everyone would
know this and that can afford me and
then I just sort of I didn't really
follow up on that I put that in the back
of my head years later this would be in
the early teens right there would be
about 2012 I was giving a lecture at the
Culinary Institute of America having to
do with the way in which we bring
together sight and hearing and taste in
what we call synesthetic perception and
I was reading through some Aristotle I
was reading Aristotle on the soul
because I
that was an important early text for
that and Aristotle was talking about
there's eight tastes and again he said
it's sort of like everyone knows this I
was like where did how did we end up
with four when these ancient people
recognized eight as is it that we just
sort of dropped them out of the picture
so I started following up on this and
when I when I would talk with colleagues
about this I got two different kinds of
responses from philosophers who are
interested in Aristotle or interested in
John Demasi and they just say yeah
that's that's just not very interesting
you know it's an interesting little
digression maybe you can write a note
about it not if not an actual full
article but but a note you know a short
piece because we're really interested in
other topics when I talked with culinary
people i often get blank stares and the
blank stares came about because some of
them were you know saying look there's
only four tastes or maybe five if we
actually accept this umami thing there's
sort of a doctrine that was out there or
they would immediately start talking
about Indian and Chinese cooking in
which there's a wide wider range of
flavors recognized so nobody as far as I
could tell until I started doing some
some you know reading around in this at
least the people that I was meeting knew
anything about there being a Western
tradition of many more tastes so when I
started looking into it I noticed a
number of references among ancient and
medieval authors to a multiplicity of
basic flavors and I also noticed that
this this for taste schema that we have
is very very recent this guy Bree at
severe on who's very important in the
the formation of gastronomy in the early
19th century he doesn't talk about it as
a matter of fact he says there's an
infinity of flavors so it's not just for
its it's too many to count according to
him and at the same time I also began to
notice not only a kind of ignorance or
lack of attentiveness to this this
history but a almost misrepresentation
of that history and I give you a hand
out that's that's an excerpt from
Jonathan layers 2003 Prust was a
neuroscientist I'm not going to like
read through this whole thing
and you can do that at your leisure but
but I want to highlight it a few things
in here so layer is claiming that
Democritus who we don't have any texts
by had said that you know shapes cause
tastes and we know that to be the case
because Aristotle tells us that another
ancient author theophrastus says that
and they're saying this because they're
criticizing the guy it fits in with what
Democritus was saying we don't know that
Democritus thought there were four
tastes as a matter of fact we have good
evidence to think that there were more
than four tastes being recognized layer
goes on and he says Plato believed
Democritus totally implausible because
play tone Democritus are a total
opposite ends of the scale and Plato
wrote in the Timaeus that that there
were just four tastes now in the Timaeus
if you read at their seven tastes and
then he goes on he says in the day
animal which is Aristotle's text the
four primary tastes Aristotle described
or the already classic sweet sour salty
and bitter except that Aristotle talks
about eight tastes there and then in
another work talks about seven tastes
because he says well there's a way in
which you can kind of crammed them
together and get seven out of it because
they really liked number numbers of
seven and then he says over the ensuing
millenia this ancient Theory remained
largely unquestioned the ancient theory
of for taste now why why is layer
bringing this up because he wants to
focus on the recent discovery which is a
real important discovery of this umami
flavor profile and but in order to do
that you don't have to pretend as if
somehow the Western tradition was this
monolithic we've only got four taste
because Democritus said so and we're
always just going to keep on plowing
away especially when we see that there
was this the whole history of other
teeth being being represented so I'm
still in the involved in research on
this I'm finding that like a lot of
academic research these are all familiar
with the term rabbit hole right you
start researching something it just
keeps going further and further down so
I'm not sure what I'm going to do with
the research but I given the opportunity
to give a talk in which I could present
some of this I thought yeah this is this
would be kind of interesting and then
and you have the great idea of well
we'll do some tasting of the actual
taste so it's not just a rather dry
academic gastronomical lecture but
something with a real gustatory
component so let me talk now about the
Greeks before Aristotle so we're talking
now about the fourth and fifth century
BC these are people at least the natural
philosophers and the physicians who were
interested in food not just to eat it
but to understand it the the physicians
were interested in it because they
thought that the tastes of things
revealed how they would affect us so
they'd already recognized by that time
that bitter things are probably bad for
us sweet things are probably wholesome
Hippocrates recognized that if things
are too sweet probably not good for us
and Hippocrates is he writes this book
called on ancient medicine so we usually
think of Hippocrates as ancient medicine
he's writing about guys even before him
and he's saying these guys screwed
things up the doctors that we've got
right now they're quacks why are they
quacks well because they do all this
speculation about the hot and the cold
and the the the dry and the wet these
are sort of basic principles for you
know there's four elements theory and
they don't pay attention to the taste
themselves and what the tastes signify
about the food so it says you know that
we have to actually focus on on how
they're mixed together he says that
tastes are too concentrated there you
know overly bitter overly salty they're
not good for us this is stuff that you
know we would probably say is accurate
today if all you're doing is eating
super salty food probably not good for
your body right if you're just drinking
straight vinegar that's probably not
going to be good for you either right
but hypocrisy is was was writing at a
time when people were prescribing this
sort of thing and he's saying don't do
that anymore Democritus who
unfortunately we don't have any writings
by just little fragments he we know from
from later writers that not only did he
distinguish flavors but that he
attributes the sense properties to the
shapes
particles and it's unclear as to what
flavors he did recognize but we know
that it wasn't just the four tastes
there were more on the docket
Hippocrates Hippocrates recognized at
least six flavors when we get to play
doh that that's on that that handout as
well we have discussion of seven flavors
seven basic flavors that are irreducible
to each other in this book the Timaeus
which Plato writes towards the end of
his life it's considered a late dialogue
it's sort of a what we call cosmology
he's trying to explain everything you
know where did the world come from why
are human beings the way they are you
know why does grass grow all these sorts
of things in it he talks about the
tongue and he says that different flavor
different particles affect our tongues
in different ways and they produce
different tastes the op shop for us is
that he says there's this taste and this
taste and this taste in this taste
they're not all just the the four tastes
that we recognize and it would be nice
if we had other documents besides that
unfortunately cooks didn't write much in
that time cooking was sort of a lower
class activity you know the sort of
thing you'd you might have your slaves
doing for you it was not something that
the people who were writing treaty sees
what would would do so it's mostly
medical writers and philosophers up up
until that point then we get Aristotle
now Aristotle is an interesting guy in
part because not only is he plato
student so he's in this lineage but he's
also in the right place at the right
time he's in the Athens he lived in a
couple other places as well but he's in
the Athens at the time that Athens is
has been brought under the Macedonian
hegemony you think of it as like a big
Empire being established there's lots of
flows of communication access to
everybody else's writings Aristotle is
also a guy who is what we call a
polymath he's interested in everything
he writes about pretty much all the
domains of science available at his
and he comes from a family of doctors
from a family of physicians so he
already attuned to thinking about the
human body and about what you give
people we see a lot of references to
medicine in his works he didn't follow
along being a doctor in his father's
footsteps but he became a philosopher
instead and he he does tell us something
interesting about the culinary arts as
opposed to somebody like play-doh this
is a little bit of a side note Plato
thought that that cookery is a bad thing
Plato thought that cookery is sort of
the the you know what you get when you
take medicine and you take all the
knowledge out of it and you turn it into
something like a capacity to flatter he
calls cookery a type of flattery
flattering the tongue all right medicine
was good for you cookery is bad for you
he also said that about you know
rhetoric as opposed to other things
rhetoric is like cookery it's it's a
kind of flattered you're just flattering
the crowd getting them to buy things so
think about it you know if you give kids
if we have kids right give them candy or
give them healthy food which do they
prefer most of the time yeah the candy
all right healthy food is a bit of a
hard sell same thing with adults that's
why we have a lot of the problems that
we do you know you have to work quite
hard to make healthy food interesting
and and tasty plato was pretty down on
cookery Aristotle thought of it as an
art whose purpose was to produce
pleasure which is not a bad thing it's
not the best thing in the world I mean
knowledge is better virtue is better
social harmony those sort of things but
you know pleasures not a bad thing and
so Aristotle was willing to think a bit
more about this than play-doh head now
he's got discussions of flavor and they
show up in several different works one
of which is called the the day anima or
on the soul the pursuit cason in Greek
and in that he distinguishes a tastes in
another work and I give you this on that
that other hand out on sense and the
sensible he tries to reduce it to seven
taste basically because he likes the
idea of there being seven the way that
he does it is he says well two of these
case can really be sort of like
assimilated to each other so there are
really eight taste he's just kind of
making it fit the schema and then he's
got another book called the physical
problems which don't actually turn out
to be physical problems there's some of
them are some of them are psychological
things that he's investigating he's got
all these sort of amusing about I wonder
what happens you know why is it that
when we eat acorns and then we drink
wine the wine appears sweeter the
questions like that he's interested in
these sorts of things so he is working
through tastes and he distinguished
eight basic flavors like I've put on the
handout for you there's the suite at one
extreme and then there's the bitter at
another extreme and he says very close
to these are the oily or the fatty the
Li patron it can be translated in a
number of ways and then the salty says
the salty is sort of like a type of
bitterness and then we've got these
other four in between and you recognize
two of them right or really you know you
recognize one of them does the sour but
then he talks about the astringent and
the pungent and this one that's hard to
translate that we usually translate as
the the rough the where is that the
ousted on we get the word aust ear from
that and he gives us a few example some
later wrist Italians give us other
examples that we can use and that's what
we're going to have you taste now so now
is the time for the big tasting
component of this talk so while Andy and
my daughter Catherine are getting all
the things together for you I think what
I'll do is while they're getting
everything out I'll tell you I'll go
through the other things about Aristotle
and that work Andy okay so one thing
that we can say about Aristotle's view
on this he thought there was like a
continuum with with sweet at one end and
bitter at the other he likens them to
the colors you know
we've got white at one end black at the
other end and of course we've got great
but he thought the other colors kind of
fit in there as well and he was
attracted to this notion that you could
maybe put them all together into the the
schema and he noticed too with colors
you had to kind of squish them together
as well he's like well can't get seven
because we've actually got eight or nine
but if we take yellow and we call that a
kind of white you know or gray and we
call that a kind of black then maybe it
all fits together so there's a little
bit of shoe morning in there as well but
for the most part he's putting these
these together he thinks that flavor
plays a very important role in
understanding what food does in our body
and now we might laugh a bit at some of
these ideas that he had because they
they don't fit our natural science
there's been a lot of advances since him
but if you think about what he's doing
it's quite interesting some of the ideas
that he has he thinks of taste as
essentially a type of touch you
recognize that the tongue is you know
has to be in contact with the things as
opposed to odor where we're just sort of
sniffing whatever happens out there and
he thinks of it as a lower sense it's
not as important which is part of why he
doesn't write much about it
unfortunately site of course is the best
sense because it reveals things to us
hearing is the second best smell is the
third best because it works at a
distance as well and then you've got you
know the body touching things and
feeling things in the tongue those are
kind of lower but he does discuss them
to some degree he also realizes that and
he has a lot of discussion of this there
has to be some sort of liquid involved
we we have to have some vehicle and he
says this is not a medium like air is
for site or for sound we have to have
some way of turning things into liquid
or we can't actually get them on our
tongue and do anything with them and
he's got some interesting speculations
about maybe this is why for example
roasted nuts tastes better when they're
actually hot than when they're cold he
says maybe that's because the
juices flowing when they're hot and it's
not flowing when they're cold and the
juice is what we actually taste so you
see him speculating about this in the
day anima the on the soul he also
rejects democritus's view that taste is
just what we would call secondary
qualities he thinks that the taste
really is out there in the thick it's
not just a subjective impression that we
have because of our particular way of
being our Constitution he thinks that
there really is sweetness in sweet
things and and there's something to that
that view I would say another thing that
he talks about is the relationship
between taste and nourishment so you
remember that continuum I said there's
sweet at one end and bitter at the other
end and then you've got all the other
things in between the sweet he thought
is what is wholesome it's it we find
things sweet because they're actually
good for us and if you think about you
know before processed foods and the
discovery of sugar cane and things like
that I think about the ancient Greek
world most of the things that actually
were sweet or worth at that end of
things we're pretty good for you you
know some of them were where he says a
bit insipid like Brad breads not really
sweet because they add a lot of sugar to
things back then but for the most part
things that our sweet are pretty good
for you things that are bitter are
usually bad for you they don't have a
lot of nutritive value now you could say
well wait a second what about you know
some of the things that we eat nowadays
because they're good for us and they're
bitter like you know cruciferous
vegetables you know we'll gather there's
something to that but they were eating
enough good food that they didn't they
didn't have to supplement quite as much
as we do back then he thought that that
heat was involved in the process of
digestion this is kind of a common view
in ancient Greek medical literature and
it carried through till the modern age
and he thought that what the he did is
allowed extraction of what was wholesome
you know what was sweet and it left
behind the bitter so he talks about the
fact that if you too much sweet stuff it
just sits in your stomach and that's
because it takes a while to today
just all that good stuff for you whereas
if you round it out with know what we
nowadays call fiber right it's going to
be much healthier for you he also
suggests that the other flavors should
be used as seasoning this goes back one
of the things I didn't mention with with
Hippocrates and with some of the earlier
thinkers was this notion that what's
good for us is proportion we need to
have some sort of structure to what it
is that we're putting together so you've
got these different tastes and you put
them together in the right way it's
going to be much better for us than if
we're taking them straight like what
you're going to be doing right now right
are we ready for it now or okay so we
all tell you a little bit more about
Aristotle and after we do the tasting so
I've got a whole script here who's very
grateful for the preparation for this I
didn't do any of this Andy and and and
my kids did all of this work for the
stuff that you're getting so the first
thing we're going to do is sweet for it
for your tasting of sweet we have three
things we've got honey a fig cake and a
newer date so these are not yeah luck
okay
ok now the honey is straight sweet this
is the example that Aristotle use for
for what is sweet that goes all the way
back to Homer this is one that I knew
about because of my interest in anger
because Homer represents anger as
sweeter than honey from the coal it's an
old old saying about that so we've got
the honey we've got the fig the fig cake
and a newer date the newer date is a bit
of a mixture because it's not just sweet
it's also a savory thing so it's mixing
some of the other flavors together did
you okay then later on in the talk at
the very end we're also going to feature
another sweet taste at the end of the
lecture using a single of fresh flower
that's that's referring to as adults a
bud and when you taste that it's really
quite interesting so go ahead and taste
the whatever you like of the the sweet
stuff yeah the honey or the the date or
the fig you don't have to have it all if
you don't want to but I know I would
what's that yeah there you go it doesn't
really flow that well does anybody have
it also does anyone have any questions
at this point while we're moving slowly
through the tastes yeah yes he did and
some of the other thinkers following in
his trace did they thought that taste
was in some respects more primary than
smell which goes against some of what we
tend to think I you plug your nose up or
you have a cold you can't really taste
much of anything they were more
interested in odors they said orders
aren't really that that describable
compared to taste taste hits you like
that odor it's kind of faint these guys
also tasted a lot of stuff that we
probably wouldn't put in our mouths too
you know like mer for example right Murr
it's nice for us to smell that you don't
want to put that in your mouth is very
bitter but they you know they thought
please try it out
oh why Kaiser no wine and vinegar would
be a good yeah he doesn't there's a lot
of discussion of wine in ancient
thinkers and they're mostly interested
in trying to classify the taste of it
rather than what transforms into what
it's a big gap and his thinking because
why does vinegar have the taste the
vinegar is sort of the representative
for them of sour this is they didn't
have a lot of the sour stuff that we
have access to so that was you know and
that comes from wine which is either
sweet or or maybe a stringent or maybe
maybe raw you know the ousted on was a
way of describing wine second thing that
we have at the total other extreme
bitter so for your tasting a bitter we
didn't want to overwhelm you with with
you know say wormwood which was one of
the examples that they often used we
gave you Cale instead and the kale is
not too bitter so you can if you like
hail go ahead and try it I think all of
you if you don't like the kale you know
what bitter tastes like we're also going
to have a bitter taste at the end of the
lecture using a method for determining
what's called super tasting but the
dandy is going to handle that part of it
as well you all a supertaster yeah we've
got some some cool stuff coming up now
remember Aristotle thought that the
bitter was unwholesome that it really
had zero nutritive value at all this is
a common view that ran throughout not
only the ancient period but the Middle
Ages see some faces out there and yeah
some people like kale some people some
people aren't so into it I mean you
think about coffee bitter taste I had
some people like coffee straight or
black others of us like I like it with
milk some people like to put sugar in it
to counterbalance that taste let me see
people shaking their head they don't
like coffee at all now the third one we
have is oily so
so for that one we've got olive oil
which is the the example that they would
use all is themselves would be in that
taste and you're not unless you really
want to just do it like a shot I don't
recommend that we've got we've got a
bagel piece for you to dip in the olive
oil as the the vehicle for that the
ancients lot of bread has more or less
tasteless it was sort of a vehicle for
for other things of course you could
have you know sweet breads or things
like that you could you could change it
but for the most part bread is pretty
simple stuff which is really I just
that's hilarious considering the ancient
grains that they were using oh yeah it
was on 11 and then figured you are
longer bread oh yeah the ancient breads
would have been just a bounding the
favor okay you ever think about the
other stuff that their contrasting it to
like wine or olives you know what's the
time frame knows bc so Aristotle we're
talking about the 4th century also
Plato's extending into the 4th century
BC so the 300s even killing each other
over no not yet but that's fairly soon
you know because once the once this you
know sort of globalization early
globalization with with the Roman Empire
and and all the way to China people are
going to get crazy I mean there's sin
dressings I was going to talk about this
literature at all but there's a whole
literature of people talking about like
famous feasts and you know they way they
would go into great debt to put on these
spreads there's a lot of discussion as
well about how to behave yourself at
dinner you know among philosophers
amongst address yeah because because
they would they would behave badly so
people thought you needed to like tell
people hey don't try to steal the best
food you know off the places it comes by
what other people have some
Daniel's nothing no I have it it's the
Dutch basically Heather island with
nutmeg yeah cut all the plants not
otherwise and their staff you're just on
the cartridge people say well oh wow so
you got to the point where a little
spice going along right yeah yeah it's
amazing the extents that people will go
to for for taste and this is you know I
think there's a gap in a lot of
philosophy not taking taste very
seriously and taking food is seriously
thought is kind of that'll take care of
itself that's this kind of a minor thing
for anything about human beings let's
think about politics instead or you know
the city or you know things like that
food is very important the next taste
that we have is salty so for your
tasting of salty we'd like to like you
to add some of the kosher salt to your
olive oil or if you want to take it some
of it straight you can do that that's
that's pretty salty by itself and then
use the other bagel piece to taste the
difference in taste with the addition of
the salt with common way to to jazz up
your olive oil you know put a bit of
salt in it I like to do that myself yeah
what I can't read that
oh ok yeah so the olives okay so while
you're doing that let me tell you a
little bit more about about Aristotle
and his his views so like I mentioned he
thought as did a lot of the Ancients
that proportion was very important you
don't want to have taste just by
themselves because that's a little bit
overwhelming it's also you know
potentially hazardous to so he talks
about this he says things are pleasant
when brought pure and unmixed into the
proportion so you have some sort of
conception of what you're working with
you try to get your ingredients as
unmixed as possible and then you mix
them together into some sort of
composition much like the way that we
think about painters you know they don't
mix all their paints together in one big
mess at the start you know they're
separate in different tubes and then
they decide what they're going to do
with that same thing with with music you
know you want your your horn to be a
pure sound you want your liar to be a
pure sound and then you bring them
together so alright so the next taste
that we're going to do is what the
Greeks called dream ooh or pungent and
this covers a lot of ground so garlic is
an example of that you know think about
things that go up your nose and make
your eyes water a bit horseradish should
be an example we have peppercorn and
sweet and tangy mustard so of course
sweet pain musters a little bit of sweet
and sour in there so feel free to try
the peppercorn yet what what is it I'm
sorry I can't hear oh okay so you use
the pretzel squares to sample the
mustard yeah yeah
so now think about this we we don't
recognize that as one of the four tastes
alright sweet sour salty bitter you
could make an argument that what we're
tasting there is not really directly a
taste that it rather it's a different
effect on the tongue and then I has to
do with what's actually going up our
nose people will make make arguments
like that the Greeks thought this is
something distinctive this is not
reducible just a sweet sour salty or
bitter this is something that we have to
recognize for its own sake you also see
this in Chinese and in Indian cuisine as
well these being recognized as separate
categories so kind of a cross cultural
perspective now the other thing that
we've got coming up that isn't there in
this in the for taste as well is the
astringent this is something that
Aristotle talks quite a bit about he
seems to be very interested in the
astringent in the physical problems i'm
not quite sure why he was interested in
that taste and not very interested than
the other ones but he was so if we were
doing this lecture later in the season
we don't offer you actual pomegranate
seeds a stringent is what makes you
pucker up it's not sour as such remember
those old cartoons you know it bugs
bunny or or wile e coyote and there was
alum and you know that somebody to eat
alum and then like the face and scrunch
up and they wouldn't have a mouth left
so that's an extreme of astringent
acorns we're an example of that you know
roast acorns and yet it's got that that
sort of makes you pucker kind of taste
people use this nowadays in candy too
you know for the kids to make certain
kinds of candy much more tasty sweet
tuts have an astringent see to them that
it's not just sour and sweet it's also
astringency so what we have for you is
cranberry prompt pomegranate juice
that's pretty straight astringent
cranberry juice by itself is rather
astringent and then we've got chocolate
covered pomegranate that's more sweet I
don't know when I was tasting them I
tasted more chocolate and some of them
more pomegranate and others but you can
try it out for yourself and we're going
to have a slightly astringent but also
somewhat different taste towards the end
a numbing taste this is this is
something that isn't in the eighth
tastes as such but is kind of
interesting to do for me and actually I
won't tell you what it tastes like so
and I want to ask you anybody but I'll
tell you afterwards we've got what's
called the Szechuan button at the end
that you'll try if you're up to it and
that will be a numbing as well as a
stringent taste the other thing that we
have that's not recognized in the for
taste the last of them is what the
Greeks called out it on and like I
pointed out we get the word austere from
that it goes straight into Latin from
the Greek outs terram and it gets used
in talking about speeches like Aristotle
talks about styles when you're talking
public speaking being very dry you know
a dry speaker not exactly the same thing
as boring but you're like yeah this is
kind of rough not really getting a lot
of pleasure out of it dry wine is an
example of that and I think that we can
associate this with with tannin which
oftentimes people want to say is just
bitterness but really there's something
different between the what's going on in
Cannon and what's going on in like if
you actually tried wormwood wormwood is
pretty bad or you know other bitter
medicines and for that what we have is
raw shelled walnuts oh of course anybody
with a nut allergy bad idea and then
we've got unsweetened black assam tea
straight t by itself not not a great for
a lot of people you know another thing
people like to put milk or sugar honey
into even lemon lemon has sweetness to
it besides sourness so that's that's why
people do that and then the last taste
that we've got is one that you recognize
which is sour so for sour tastes we
might expect things like lemon we're
focusing on vinegar in part because the
Greeks didn't didn't you
you know I mean nowadays Greeks use
lemon in a lot of cooking right but back
then the most sour thing that thickets
gets talked about in all this literature
is vinegar because it was it was all
over the place they'd use it for
seasoning so we've got some vinegar
potato chips you know we're blessed in
having a million different flavors of
potato chips these days yet oh that's
right yeah yeah okay and at the end
we're going to do a sour to sweet taste
experiment what using a supplement
derived from what's called a miracle
berry and we'll use a lemon wedge in a
tangerine half that you've got there in
that tasting so don't eat them up right
now but you know we and we have palate
cleansers too if people need them don't
ear or just the water okay just the
water okay so while you're finishing up
at that I'll tell you just a few other
things about Aristotle then well we'll
run through some of the other history
none of the things that Aristotle talks
about quite a bit is this common
experience of people differing or being
off about about tastes so they knew that
people who are ill there's a common
example people who are ill taste things
differently things taste bitter to them
that are actually sweet or other flavors
in the day sensu Aristotle says that
there are some people who are much more
discriminating in their sense of taste
nowadays we often call them you know
super tasters or we talk about people
developing their palate in the probe
LaMotta he has an example of drinking
wine after eating rotten fruit I'm not
sure why people were eating rotten fruit
back then but he talks about that he
says well people eat the rotten fruit
and the wine tastes bitter and the
reason why it tastes bitter is because
they've got the bitterness already on
their tongue and then when they're
adding the wine you've got more liquid
and so the wine itself is being you
might say corrupted by that yeah Jesse
you had a question
oh the extrude not the estranged of the
rough the the austere own yeah yeah he
also talks like I mentioned if you eat a
stringent food like he gives the example
of acorns or myrtle berries I've never
had a Myrtle bury myself I'm not even
sure what they would look like but I
guess this is kind of a common thing to
eat back then it'll make the wine taste
sweeter and like I said we see this with
sweet tarts except they're not you know
first one then the other they just put
them together in the candy the
astringency makes the sweetness come out
sort of like you know when we're
contrasting clothes right we're a blue
jacket and the orange shirt there's the
orange is going to pop more as opposed
to say gray shirt you know the other
thing that he talks about that i think
is kind of interesting is in the day
anima and this is the thing that I was
supposed to be researching in the first
place that got me interested in this
whole thing was how the senses are
brought together through what he calls
the common sense or the common sensibles
you know when we when we see things do
we see them and know that they're going
to be sour not just because we've
already associated that in our head
while lemons are sour stuff like that
can we look at things and tell whether
they're going to be of a certain taste
or not Aristotle thinks that we can and
and use did a very interesting
experiment with her students where they
would play a bit of music and try to
associate that with a flavor profile but
there's a lot of sort of what we call
synesthetic perception I and when I say
Stannis Anastasia i don't mean the
disorder that some people have whether
you know seeing how they're seeing
flavors or or you know tasting colors or
things like that I mean what we normally
do which is to see you know the
whiteness of the paper and know that
this is soft without actually touching
it there's things like that that we can
do with with taste as well that
Aristotle thought so while you nosh on
you know other stuff your leisure let me
tell you about these how this played out
in later times
so there are a lot of people who write
about this and I've got a number of them
listed here but I'm not going to
necessarily bring all of them up because
I want to stay on track what I will say
is that throughout the Middle Ages
throughout the the earlier period the
ancient period leading into the Middle
Ages and even through the modern period
there wasn't a lot of attention coming
to this in any written way by people who
were primarily interested in culinary
arts that's going to be a later
development unfortunately because I
would love to know what the monks who
had gardens were doing with this
knowledge of the tastes or what was
going on in you know Royal kitchens as
far as these tastes most of the sources
that we have our philosophers
theologians medical writers some of them
do actually engage in some some cookbook
stuff but it's mostly in terms of
medicine so there are some one had a
friend named Theophrastus Theophrastus
will take over Aristotle school after
Aristotle dies we don't have everything
that that fail fastest wrote
unfortunately one of the losses that's
really unfortunate is theophrastus
actually wrote a book about tastes are
about flavors that's gone we I was just
talking with Scott about this before the
the presentation that we probably have a
estimating conservatively maybe a fifth
of what was written in the ancient world
in philosophy we have these these lists
of all these books that we don't have
anymore and so unfortunately we don't
have that era therefore estes did
discuss a lot of other things up so if
you're interested in this topic he's got
books like the causes of plants or the
inquiry into plants why plants are
important well because plants taste like
things and use them in medicine he has a
book on orders where he also discusses
taste and so he ends up basically
talking about seven tastes although you
know he's working off of Aristotle so
it's really a taste Galen you may
heard of him he was another ancient
medical writer he's kind of eclectic
he's bringing things in from from
everybody and he discusses tastes and
previous thinkers classifications he
tends to use Plato seven taste but he
changes the wording and then sometimes
ads in depending on the work other
flavors sometimes assimilates flavors to
each other so there's already some
variance going on another guy in MSC
asst in his day natural home eNOS draws
and Aristotle and Galen discusses a
taste this would be in the fourth
century and fifth century John Philip
onus again in the 5th 6th century he
writes a comment area what's up easy
read ad all this is ad at this point he
he writes a commentary on Aristotle and
this became a thing to do Aristotle was
an important writer so if you write a
commentary on the unaired settles book
where he discusses the a taste you've
got to discuss it and what's important
about Philip onus is he gives us
examples because some of these are hard
to relate to what what is austere own
you know well he's the one who tells us
dry wine that's that's the taste of it
you know some other no-brainers honey
his sweet olive oil is boilie you know
but he's useful for telling us about
other things and he does in fact talk
about pepper he uses pepper as the
example by then but by now you know
we've got trade trade one established
jhanda masking that would be in that
spicy or or pungent yeah it'd be the
what the Greeks are calling the dream Oh
John de masking like I mentioned he
talks about these then there's this guy
who is a we don't know anything about
him his biography his name as eben ser
all were rock and he writes a very
famous cookbook and it's got 132 and he
discusses the eight tastes and he
correlates them to traditional cooking
using recipes that are coming from the
Baghdad of his time so Baghdad was a
really important city a lot of the
colleagues their courts
Baghdad lots of you know cooking going
on at the court lots of other people
living around there cooking things he
wants he's interested in health and in
you know if you're dealing in this way
you need this kind of dish because it's
got these taste going on another
important Muslim thinker ovid sinha he
he's commenting on an era Aristotle to
some degree but he he also discusses
drugs he was he was a doctor himself and
he works in terms of these elements and
principles and he talks in terms of the
eight tastes he actually discusses what
these tastes are supposed to do
medically so he'll say that the bitter
is good for cleansing and corseting the
rough is good for whatever squeezing is
I'm not quite sure what that means I
still have to do more research on that
boilie soothing makes sense right and in
heat adhesion pungency dissolving and
diluting and so on and so forth he
becomes yeah so we're rock is in the
900s and then abbott santa is writing in
the early well after the beginning of
the new millennium he dies in 1037 then
we get another another person Vincent's
of Beauvais now we're back to the to the
West he writes a book called the
speculum ious which is sort of like a
natural history we would call her he's
trying to make sense of the whole world
he's read Ovid Senna he talks about the
eight tastes in terms of waters and the
kinds of waters that you might encounter
and how to fix them if they're unhealthy
for you by adding certain things to them
which would alter their quality so you
notice everybody is using the eight
tastes at this time it's not a a
reference just to the fourth case
there's a number of other people Thomas
Aquinas big you know medieval thinker
that that a lot of people know for other
reasons he comments on aristotle's de
anima he actually thought that we could
again squish these tastes together
because he was commenting on the descent
suit where Aristotle's doing that so he
he says well really the the astringent
and the pond the pungent are the same
thing that's kind of a stretch I don't
really buy that but but he thought that
he also thought that we could correlate
it to these humors and the dry and the
wet and the hot and the cold yeah maybe
the godfather of our Thomas no no
because he he recognized he still got
seven right and there were other people
like Galen Galen will depending on what
book he'll he'll blend them together or
he'll say really these two are like
Gayle and thinks that the the astringent
and the dry or the Diaw steer are really
the same thing just varying in degree
you know so it's a good it's an
important question though this is
something that we'll talk about a little
bit later on is is there a fundamental
difference in in just degree or is it a
different what we call modality you know
so if it's a totally different taste
it's a different modality yeah spices in
the world thinking of one taste well
they didn't because here we go basically
you look at this yeah cinnamon would be
sweet so other other spices some are
bitter some some are more dry yeah you
just if that actually some of them would
be mixed to you know they wouldn't
what's up every go paprika so
yeah I mean smoked paprika a really a
really depends it just seems to me that
that's a very but you know it seems like
you're then categories on oh well it's
not that everything is a pure thing in
each category so you could have you
could have like maybe something has got
a lot of bitterness and a bit of
astringency and a bit of sweetness these
are sort of thinking to sort of like the
scale of musical notes right you can
make lots and lots of chords and the
chords are very different from each
other but they still boil down to the
same basic array although you know we do
we also do have interesting scales of
music where like they've got the quarter
tones right now we're Indian music has
other tones so so maybe that's that's
not a good example there's some other
people that start to we get into the
Renaissance this guy gasps spiral canta
canta rini he's an alchemist he's also a
church official he suggests that there's
eight basic flavors but then he says you
know we could probably make up new ones
because cooking changes them and adds
new things that aren't already there
jean-françois fenna furnell who coins
the term physiology he said he's the
guys that start suggesting that taste
buds are sensitive to fat something that
scientists poo-pooed for a long time and
are now starting to take seriously again
as a possibility that would be those
guys would be 1400s 1500s thomas willis
this would be the 1600s he's an English
physician he proposes nine basic tastes
another very influential guy now Maya
grew who's a physician and botanist said
there's at least 16 simple tastes that
could maintain their unique qualities so
now we're starting to see more
differentiation right and he says for
example horse radishes is aqua switch
you thought of as pungent and hot at the
same time there's a guy John floyer who
writes a treatise on asthma who
discusses the the flavors and how they
could contribute to having better health
in terms of getting over as much big
problem I guess
the time careless Linnaeus who you guys
know from you know botany he discusses
the taste as well he says there's nine
tastes and then he later on ads in and
I'm not quite sure what these are
supposed to be aqueous can the watery in
some sense and then nauseous taste that
make us I want a pure okay I don't know
exactly what that flavor profile would
be like but you probably would you proud
what's up yeah we save that one for
later and then there's other people too
that are they're doing this and then we
get this guy who's really important for
gastronomy because he's one of the
fathers of the the discipline jean
briault at severn he writes a book
called the physiology of taste in the
early 19th century and he doesn't think
there's four takes you think there's an
infinity of flavors that we can't
possibly categorize them so then the
question that we're left with is well
where did we get for tastes from and if
we want to understand that we have to
think about sort of what was going on in
the mid 19th century in early 20th
century in terms of you know apply
science to everything but it was a
rather reductive understanding of
science there was sort of an
intersection of anatomy and chemistry
and culinary arts and sciences and
psychology is developing as a discipline
apart from philosophy where it
originally had its home Aristotle's de
anima is on the soul that on the sukkah
psychology they start to like to really
measure things and measuring is great
I'm all for it but but sometimes you
wind up only measuring certain things
and leaving out the rest so this notion
that only what is measurable with what
we can measure right now can can
sometimes be a bit stultifying they
start to narrow what's understood as
flavor or taste to what would be
chemically reproducible or in terms of
the modalities of sensation they start
stripping away these tastes so the maybe
the astringent can just be reduced to
the bitter right or
maybe the dryness of tannin maybe that's
just a form of bitterness or sourness or
whatever there's a lot of controversies
between these researchers about whether
these are distinct flavors in terms of
qualities or in terms of what they call
modalities and you might say well what
was the why care about that if they're
just qualities then they could be in
some way reduced to each other if
they're modalities then they're
irreducible but they were also saying
look some of the things that we consider
taste are not actually modalities of
taste their modalities of other things
so think about pungent pneus right if it
what's going on is your nose is acting a
certain way that's not really taste so
they're pushing that aside and in 1927
we get this guy Hans henig and he comes
up at the foretaste tetrahedron which
which you might have seen they're really
interested in identifying the chemical
constituents receptor sites and
mechanisms and then we get this guy
boring who wasn't really boring but he
made a mistake he in his in the 40s he
misinterpreted Hennings research which
he had to do with relative sensitivity
of the tongue he's the guy we got the
tongue chart from he's the reason why we
think that sweet only happens here when
sweet is actually diffused across the
entire tongue there the guy who made the
mistake or the guy who boring
b-o-r-i-n-g yeah I mean just like it's
yeah yeah but so what what's going on is
is they are engaging in something that
makes sense scientifically but they're
there eventually leaving out what we
would call the phenomenological
perspective how things actually do
appear to us how we live them up and now
you notice that what's what's going on
in recent years is there's been kind of
a swing to the other extreme so it took
a long time before this year's are all
familiar with you mommy taste which we
don't actually have a thing for here and
isn't represented I think in a taste
unless maybe oily is kind of like it the
Imam
thing is that the thing that mushrooms
give us that beef gives us that you know
good phoned at the bottom of a pan gives
us it's kind of all how would you
describe its kind of overall wholesome
taste to it such as it seems older than
it is yeah really and that's why we love
mushrooms there's more depth to it
that's why sucky one is sucky a really
great yeah so it took a long time for
people to say yeah there could be a
possibility of this because that for
taste orthodoxy was so strong now
researchers are saying yeah maybe fat is
actually tasted by the tongue that would
be what Aristotle called the oily taste
right spiciness or pecan says something
they talk about that's similar to the
the you know the pungent although not
perhaps exactly the same people also
talk in terms of and this is not in the
a taste but metallic taste we do taste
metal right I mean pull your tongue out
don't do it is cold of course because I
don't have a piece of metal and it does
have a distinct taste coolness what what
mint gives us when we when we eat mint
carbon dioxide it's turning out that we
we sense you know that's why we like
carbonated beverages and so there could
potentially be a lot of others if we're
only thinking in terms of taste
receptors then maybe on the tongue maybe
there are only five but what goes into
taste is a lot more than just what
happens in the tongue it's about the
mouth feel it's about what goes on with
our nasal passages at what it's what
goes on with a lot of other things so
I'm not actually advocating that we
should try to return to the eight tastes
of Aristotle any more than I would say
that you know we have to use all the
rest of Aristotle's natural science
because that would be a catastrophe but
I want it the whole reason I wanted to
talk about this is because I think it's
very interesting that there's this
entire tradition spanning most of our
history here in the west of recognizing
an entire multiplicity of taste that got
left out which now we're gradually
starting to reincorporate so that's
that's pretty much the end of my
gastronomic
stuff and I think we can do some Q&A and
then Andy's got some cool stuff for you
coming up and I'll let her actually take
over at that point yeah sweet yeah you
mean like that peppercorn but but like
green peppers through yeah yeah I mean
the hot peppers would be would be in the
realm of what the Greeks are recognizing
as the pungent sweet peppers would be
sweet and then you could have anything
in between when we when we smoked like
smoked paprika we're adding a different
taste to which I don't think they really
had in that schema that's a good
question yeah one question was thinking
about when we describe some things you
talk about it and just kind of journey
ended science Oh researching yeah yeah
there's there's really no one single
time because the medical writers were
interested in food from the beginning
and ancient medicine I mean it didn't
have a hell of a lot to work with
besides what you eat and what you did
for exercise surgery was not developed
you know they had an array of drugs that
they would use but a lot like
Hippocrates is a huge advocate of eating
the right sort of things and you're
going to be healthy now whether that's
scientific from our current perspectives
not really very much but there was some
empirical analysis but it's not like
they're doing you know double-blind
studies or anything like that right but
so it's like a continuum as time goes on
there's more and more and more of it the
Islamic world was in
in the Middle Ages was where a lot of
that was taking place they were they
were very far advanced compared to us
over here in the West as far as what
would diet did to our bodies there's a
whole story that can be told there but
why why that that you know went into
decline but so yeah there's if we want
like hard science where people are
publishing things in journals in the
19th 20th century yeah punch in your
research morning yeah I mean they quit
food as medicine yep and did centuries
before I would even say well maybe at
the same time the Greeks did learn any
more profound way so we're getting a
system for it I don't know how much it
was written yeah yeah I mean we know
that there's that going on we also know
that the Islamic researchers talking
about the 80's influence Indian stuff so
I have it sent up for example gets read
quite a bit in India in the Middle Ages
but there's already a native sort of
tradition of that going on and I I don't
do much with that myself because in part
you know my research tool languages are
Greek Latin French German and then
English yeah right I don't I can't read
Sanskrit or Arabic yeah yeah I'm Alaska
the doshas were established at second
century yeah there's any
you know and again it's so unfortunate
that we don't have written documents
although we could discover them because
we know that there is a lot of cultural
interchange once Alexander the Great had
this conquest the bactrian kingdoms are
established this is like you know 4th
century BC India as a cultural as a
civilization and the West were brought
into contact and a lot of things start
flowing back and forth but we don't we
don't really know you know when it comes
to that and then there's China to you
know there's there's an a the five
elements philosophy goes back very far
there's five tastes associated with that
yeah any yeah go ahead yeah there's a
lot of theories why the pythagorean's
didn't eat beans and we don't really
know whether any of them are actually
accurate is probably in some ways good
advice you know some of the time don't
eat a lot of beans right but you know
actually the pythagoreans are one of the
things that is is strangely absent in
this so in ancient philosophy right an
ancient thought in general you have
these schools of philosophers and the
pythagorean's worry school founded by
Pythagoras the guy that we get the
Pythagorean theorem from probably or
maybe one of his friends because they
attribute everything good to him and
they were all about number they were all
about order you would think that they
probably had something to say about
taste we don't have any of that
unfortunately it's one of those losses
and we don't see anybody else referring
back to them and saying that they
contributed in some way to this so it's
too bad you know I would love to see so
much of ancient literature that we've
lost be available to us because then we
pour through it you had a question today
as this is the
felt weird question is a drink of my
wonderful aqua what's the taste of water
yeah dad say I mean if you get back
before the crucifixion Virginia oh yeah
sour wine yeah I'm take even just the
things people who drink a day to day to
be healthy I would guess would have a
bit of a sour taste well because yeah
from i'm getting i get mixed people
mixed answers from people in a lot more
than I do which isn't hard yeah but it
took the thief the water wasn't really
good oh so sort of wine or beer or even
vinegar which would all not taste like
water yeah i mean it is at all into the
taste I mean a lot of people drank water
in ancient Greece more I think in the
Middle Ages was like you just wouldn't
drink water if you could help it and it
varied from area to area the the wines
like I was talking about there are a lot
of discussions of this wine tastes this
way this wine tastes this way we've got
a lot of that we don't have a lot of
other things they were mostly interested
in their their wine drinking in the
living room you know that in fish sauce
they really love the fish sauces yeah
well I think they'd probably put that in
with oily you know but you're right i
mean that that is a lack we've talked
about the smoky taste tues I mean we
know they smoke things yeah I guess you
know
she so the fish would have been coached
so she needs yeah yeah salamander
probably smoked for preservation salted
certainly yeah and smoke or seasoning in
some way that we can imagine unripe
grape juice was used also as a book
preservative and as a sour aspect yeah
that would make sense marinade then it
goes way back from antiquity yeah and
grapes worthwhile when everywhere and
used 54 and rocky life yeah you know the
astringent taste to a lot of the ancient
authors will talk about unripe fruit as
being a stringent not grapes but like
pears quince things like that and if you
get if you go to quince today I actually
was hoping we could use quince for this
but we couldn't find any on the market
easily that would be not quite right
that is really that really makes your
mouth pucker up it's like it's like
almost like eating a sweet tart well
it's not that long ago mean if you look
at books on the menu they have in the
Titanic movie gypsy looking under the
boxing together god this is there while
tastes even a hundred years ago this we
wouldn't do today yeah there were a lot
of people eating a lot of food back then
like having a steak with with you know
all sorts of other things on top of it
for breakfast and people writing about
that in discussions of like late 19th
early 20th century like city eating are
you getting ready for the the other
thing well I'll take whatever other
questions we did you have a question
very
ah the hot peppers those are a new world
new world origins okay Jews can't really
go back to these past global authorities
well he didn't say that yeah yeah yeah
they talked about things like garlic for
example you know they didn't use hot
peppers is no Jambo yeah yeah that's
that's true yeah oh yeah I mean think
about all the stuff that was coming in
you know it we sprinkle salt and pepper
and his family like no think about but
imagine how much that changed yeah
there's yeah you know there's a famous
story they don't remember where it comes
up it's around the French Revolution and
there's a sadistic rat he's trying to
get out of Paris and he's he's in
disguise so he's pretty you know made
himself look like a peasant he goes into
an end and he says you know do you want
anything for breakfast he all have an
omelette and almost were kind of common
back then and they asked the guy fine
how many eggs because I guess that was
the common thing to do he says well
about a dozen because that was what he
was used to eating you know now of
course they realized immediately and
then he was guillotined yeah too much
salt yeah his master the salt yeah did
you are you ready or are there any other
quick yeah
sort of observing this and it seems like
what makes food pleasant to enjoy and
tasting it yeah is combining yes and I
think today we probably combine things
differently than we say we did have a
Titanic and no go back farther and it
was even different plus different
cultures we just got back from Morocco
they don't put salt and pepper on their
eggs they put coolant on their base oh
okay I mean if cultures are different
too yeah and the combining of the
flavors is what makes it interesting and
what people like I think yeah Roman
legions when they brought their garden
that cumin goes back a long ways in the
West I you know I remember when I was a
kid and this just shows how I grew up
here in Wisconsin and in the 70s I
remember I was in fourth grade and there
was a kid who their parents there was
having a birthday party and it was the
first time that I had tacos and what
tacos were back then were that Ortega
mix that you get yeah that and then the
hard shell tacos and we never had
anything like that I was like oh my gosh
this is so great you know and of course
everybody on the street he had to have
tacos and it was like you know a thing
but the tacos that we're having were you
know those aren't real tacos yeah but it
was such a you know the sounds of what
we were eating was bland it just didn't
have that thing in it and and there's so
much that gets contributed now I think
unfortunately kind of swung to the other
extreme where we have so much of
industry trying to combine a million
different things together and and it
might be better for us to get away from
some of the super abundance of choice I
here's how to graph I arranged through
yeah that's tough problems we have
chemically some of these flavors can be
reproduced oh yeah we got chemicals yea
rather than natural ingredients and I
think that's where we're running into
the problem that was something they were
really interested in in the early 20th
century how could you anowar gave an
impetus to this in particular how
because you were cut off from access to
say vanilla right so how do you how do
you make vanilla artificially right and
so it spawned this entire industry of
things that could supplement and there's
a lot of different artificial flavors
out there so that's a good or did you
have another question I worry the other
roles would you allow what my
understanding give me the fish sauce
sauce yeah it's a deep bullpen be found
some other yes it's yeah handed
extremely extremely song pointed out
unpalatable kemana aja King Stannis I've
heard that one that might be so probably
slid in the book where and people who
ate all eating from nana they lost their
keys or so yeah i don't know but i don't
know about that particular thing i can
tell you this that the Romans had a
massive problem with lead because they
used it in their pipes too and so it was
in the baths it was in all the other
running water that they had they used it
in cookware
oh that's and that's like later on
that's yeah we're gonna weeks to lab
yeah oh oh my god the chemical needs to
let oh interesante interest in land sure
okay no cigarettes they go together yeah
so it makes it so tough to quit when
you're smoking yeah but I mean so so
that they yeah I mean they you can say
that they made everything much more
salty by by using this fish sauce but
they didn't use on everything you know I
mean we've got records of Roman meals
where like they love to do all sorts of
variety when it was possible but yeah
they certainly did use a lot of it well
it the lovely hookers either they had a
much greater tolerance or salted mana
people with or it just wouldn't taste it
I think it's more like you know you got
some people put ketchup on everything
other people who don't like the rest of
us you know it's that way we don't get
the impression from at least what I've
read in Roman literature that fish sauce
is going on everything for most people I
mean that wouldn't you'd have to have a
ton of fish sauce to make that possible
and you know we read about these great
feasts that they had and they'll
describe and pretty great detail but
what's what's being set before them I
think a lot of thats you know involved
and trying to like show what a big shot
you were to have a lot of different yeah
you're wrong minute 34 any yeah I mean
they didn't know that they didn't know
that sodium in high quantities wasn't
good for us but they didn't know a lot
of I mean they didn't know lead wasn't
good for us right so you know we didn't
know that much about it either look at
lead paint when even just my generation
was a kid so well should we do the other
components then thanks for for your
attention is a very long story so really
really great questions I'm going to turn
it over to Andy who's going to lead you
through all sorts of other interesting
culinary things
you